(high pitched engine whirs)
- If people could understand that
this is akin to the scariest
thing you've ever done,
then they'll start to understand why
we're so addicted to it.
When I put the goggles on,
the first thing I'm doing
is trying to calm down.
(hip hop music)
It totally puts you inside the drone.
You just forget where you are.
(hip hop music)
(acoustic guitar picking)
I'm Conrad Miller, also known as Furadi
and I'm a drone racer.
(acoustic guitar picking)
I started in September
2014 and that was like
the ground floor.
(hip hop beat)
Of all the activities I've partaken in,
motorcycles and flying drones
are on the same level
in terms of intensity.
Wooh.
It's cool when you have a hobby
and you can do it and you love it.
But when you can share it with your kids,
that's just like what
it's all about I think.
Okay so the props are good.
Flying and racing with Sorell
has just been a pure joy.
He's a good kid and he's a talented kid.
And I think it comes
easy to any kid like that
because they don't feel the
pressure that adults do.
Good landing (chuckles).
- [Sorell] Comin' in hot.
- This is harder than
anything else I've done
and it's because when your nerves go,
your fine motor skills go.
Kids don't care, they're just having fun
and they just learn much faster.
(hip hop beat)
The course in L.A. is
at the Hawthorne Mall
which is abandoned.
It's been abandoned
since the 80's I believe
and it looks like a
place where you would go
if there was a zombie apocalypse.
(high pitched motors whiz)
(racers cheer and applaud)
When I go into races I feel like I put
a lot of pressure on myself to win.
I want all of my practice and
all of my time flying
to show for something.
(motor whizzes and crashes)
(crowd ooohs)
I was flying fine, I wasn't nervous, but,
I was just a little too high and crashed.
- You like almost hit the ceiling,
you were like, mmmmm, phffffs.
- Everybody is just working
really hard to be the best at it
and it's just gonna get
tougher and tougher.
I take that 180 good.
- Yeah you did.
- Flying with Sorell
now, it kinda gives me an
opportunity to look at it
from a different perspective
cause I can coach him.
You ready?
- [Sorell] Mmhmm.
- Go for it.
(high pitched motors whir)
He's aware enough to know that
he gets to do these things that
most kids don't get to do.
He's flying a drone, which is
this ground breaking thing.
(plastic crashes)
(laughter)
- Dang it!
We hit each other!
- You hit me!
What are you talking
about, "We hit each other?"
You know as parents,
we don't always feel like we do enough.
I brought him into drone racing and
he knows he’s lucky and
he knows he's fortunate.
Yeah kiddo, you were goin' pretty quick.
And you know, he's grateful
for everything that he gets.
(electronic beat music)